a few weeks ago I had a conversation
with Jonathan pazzo and you'll see that
we're in his basement having a
conversation of which so much of it will
end up going in the documentary this
interview by the way is for this
conversation is for a documentary called
better left unsaid which is all about
answering the question when does the
Left go too far
Jonathan's basement got flooded because
if you follow the news and Ottawa there
was a huge flood just a few weeks ago so
none of what you see is around anymore
it's completely rotted and underwater
and there's a GoFundMe page in the
description for you to donate to him so
that he can get some semblance of a life
back the conversation that we had has so
many nuggets of gold that I want to just
put I want to make my whole documentary
just this conversation but I'm putting
it online here for you instead and I'll
select the best parts and put it in the
documentary enjoy so I'm here with the
preeminence the exigence the pivotal
paramount Jonathan pazzo
artist Carver public speaker symbolic
translator I guess yeah you could say
that something like that why don't you
just tell me about what you do tell
everybody about what you do it's a but
tell me all right well I I'm mostly an
artist I make religious art liturgical
art you could call it in the Orthodox
tradition but in general and let's say
the kind of Christian medieval tradition
and that has led me to look into
symbolism in the Christian tradition but
also in general looking at other
religions other traditions but through
other types of storytelling as well
fairytales mythology and now modern
storytelling such as movies and novels
and everything and so looking into
symbolic structures relating to my art
has led me to becoming becoming
interested in symbolism in general and
so in my daily practice and I make in
making icons I engage in that world
let's say that symbolic world through my
art making and then the way that that
art integrates into the life of a church
and in the life of a community is also
part of that but then now for the past I
guess two years now I've been doing a
lot
more public speaking talking about
symbolism in general how it relates to
our life how it its structures are the
inform our perception of reality and are
interacting with reality so that's what
I've been doing through YouTube but also
doing a lot of public speaking all over
North America for the past two years
Ness you said that you got started
because you were an artist
and so you started studying the symbolic
representations and what they mean but
give me a timeline of your life so you
were four years old and use this and
then you were well I know I when I was
young I always kind of knew I was going
to be an artist from when I was pretty
young but then I was also my parents
were a Christian I was a Christian I was
part of a evangelical church and then
when I studied in college when I studied
at Concordia University painting and
drawing I really hit a wall it was just
contemporary art is an art which is very
removed from what it's doing you know
it's like a comment upon a comment upon
a comment all right it's not another
word for modern art or is that different
well Maude I'm contemporary art you
would say you could you could use modern
for the whole period but usually we use
the word modern for the early 20th
century up to about World War two and
then after World War two we start to
talk about moving towards what we could
call postmodern art or contemporary art
which is even more let's say removed
from more a comment like I said a
comment upon a comedy because about art
itself it becomes a kind of circular
playing with elements of the art piece
of art that was just a urinal yes well
that was modern without modern but
Duchamp who made that urinal is seen as
a one of the seminal figures in bringing
about what would be today installation
art and contemporary art so there are
certain figures in modernism which lead
into what we now consider people like
Jeff Koons or Andy Warhol you know they
they take their their dry from people
from people from people like messages
shots beginning of the century so it was
already already there at the beginning
of the century let's say everything was
kind of packaged up and then it unfurled
itself into now the kind of on one hand
anything goes but on the other hand
everything has to be packed
a kind of post cynical you know ironic
double irony triple irony so that's
really what it is so it was very
difficult for me coming in as someone
who wanted to connect with reality you
know who as a person of faith I wanted
to make things which which weren't just
this flighty irony you know of
references but wanted to connect with
something real and so I was just hitting
a wall I just couldn't couldn't make it
happen I got interested in some
contemporary artists for example there's
a German artist his name is Anselm
Kiefer and he was the closest to what I
was hoping to do he was he was trying to
bring back mythological thinking within
the artwork but his work was still it's
still problematic because it's still in
galleries it's still prestige objects
objects which have no function in the
world right
we're actually so used to thinking that
art doesn't have a function in the world
that we forget that traditional arts in
all cultures actually have functions
within a community they they integrate
themselves within a worldview within a
community living um
and so and it's not conscious do they
consciously construct the arts so that
they're integrating one another or does
that happen because they're communally
putting together a piece of art and then
they all respect it and revere it and it
has their values embedded in it somehow
well the traditional way of seeing art
is very different from the contemporary
way of seeing art the way that
traditional vision pretty much I would
say worldwide you see art as a skill and
so the notion of art is we still use
that word today when we say the art of
cheese-making or the art of this the art
of that and so that that's really the
traditional way of understanding the
word art the word art actually means in
Latin comes from the notion of fitting
things together so the capacity to fit
things together properly that's what art
is and so in a traditional vision of art
we say things like the art remained with
the artist right the art is the skill of
making things and so the the object that
is made has to serve a purpose there's
no such thing in a traditional vision as
making art you don't make art you use
art to make things and so the artist
art is the tool art is the skill art is
the the capacity that you have mastered
to make an object and so then that
objects needs to have a function in the
world it needs to be integrated within a
purpose and that's probably one of the
hardest things for people to understand
is that art is not a value in itself and
once you understand that at least when I
understood that it actually liberated my
me
from a lot of problems because one of
the problems we're always asking is is
this art is this art you know you you
they they come up with some crazy Jeff
Koons you know blown up Snoopy and then
that question is is that art and the
answer to me now has become I don't care
that's that doesn't matter
that's not the point the whether it's
art or not that's not that's not a
question
the question is does it does it matter
does it have meaning does it have a
function is it is it integratable into
society like does it have a capacity to
integrate into the world and so when i
all of this was kind of playing around
in my head while I was studying fine art
and it was so funny because it was so
taking that that became the subject of
my art and so the subject of my art in
college was how can I make art in this
postmodern world which is not just
ironic which is actually connected to a
community to to to let's say a coherent
worldview but then it was it was still
being very removed it was like I'm not
doing it I'm asking myself whether I can
do it and it was so funny because the
last my last day in school when my
supervisor was giving me my final grade
she said it was so funny because I
actually finished first in my program
like I was really diligent I was working
hard but she knew that it just wasn't
working and she she just looked at me
and said don't worry you're getting all
A's it's okay
what does she know was not working was
she understood that if what I was trying
to do which is for example to be a
Christian person who was making art in a
manner which was authentic
and but was still somehow part of the
contemporary art world which is full of
irony and full of double let's say
double removal and constant you know a
kind of flighty remove version of
reality she just knew that it it wasn't
wasn't happening and so she just she
just told me on the very last day of my
of my degree she said what are you doing
here like you don't you don't belong
here
you should go to seminary or something
you know you're too traditional no
because she could see that the questions
I was asking we're not they just it just
wasn't fitting with the with the
contemporary art world it just didn't
have its place the questions such as
such as the utility of asking whether or
not a piece of art is a piece of art no
no not that that that is something that
everybody is always constantly asking
the the problem was mostly to say how
can I let's say as part of a community
let's say a part of a Christian
community how can I make objects which
fit into my life and into my world and
into my community in an integrated way
you know like I mean it's it's it really
is a difference between I didn't know
yes because I hadn't discovered
traditional art it really is the
difference between let's say I make
you're a musician and you come to me and
you say here's my here's what I'm trying
to play this what I'm doing then I
design a guitar for your particular
needs
that's traditional art right but and the
postmodern version of that would be the
postmodern version of that would would
be I will make a guitar that will
question what a guitar is right I will
make a guitar that cannot cannot be
played but will will ironically question
the whole tradition of what of what
guitars have been in with music and and
then now today it's even worse because
now it's going to show how the the
guitar itself as an object whose created
by by hierarchies of historical
hierarchies how does it how is it a an
object which which manifests or subverts
that hierarchy you know that's the
that's the difficulty of post-modernism
so that so I would that's not what I was
wanting to do you know that that's not
what that's not what I was trying to do
is trying to create a Lang visual
language which was which would integrate
with my own
experience with my own faith with my own
participation in the community in the
church and all that okay let's get back
we're gonna get back to this but let's
get back to art as a tool yes they're
saying art is a tool so this Snoopy
example I don't know the reference I
don't get good enough who's this big
Snoopy yeah well I don't think he made a
big so he made he makes like for example
he did he did a big a big sculpture
which is a pile of play-doh so likely
imagine like a lot a small child has
taken bits of play-doh and you just kind
of jump bundle up in nothing
he made a giant bronze sculpture of a
pile of play-doh
okay Jeff Koons okay so makes things
like that so this amalgamation of
play-doh is an art near quite your
answer is it doesn't matter what matters
more is doesn't matter and does it
provide meaning to a certain set of
people and does it integrate that people
with the community I don't know if I'm
yeah it's how does it integrate into the
world how does it participate in the
world how does it build instead of in
that I think that then if it does then
it's art or no it's not about the
question of whether art art the art
itself is the skill right it's the
capacity to do that that's what that's
it that's the traditional worldview so
art so let's take another example let's
say someone's making some someone's a
great pizza maker yeah and then they
make something let's say they made it
out of pizza but they're good pizza
makers so then the question is is that
pizza and you would say well did they
use the skill of pizza making on that
object the question would be is it good
cuz that's what it teaches supposed to
do can you eat it yes and does it taste
good if you want to know if whether or
not that that that pizza maker is a good
artist is whether or not the pizza does
with the pizzas supposed to do which is
taste good you know whatever it is that
you could it could be to be healthy to
it depending on what the the pizza maker
wants to accomplish by making his pizza
you know it's the same thing with
someone like I said somebody would make
a musical instrument the question if you
ask whether or not that that you know
the the musical instrument maker is a
good artist is whether or not that
instrument does what it's supposed to do
and that's it's very difficult for
people to think that way now
you know because even in the past music
was composed for reasons we don't people
didn't just compose music just to
compose music they
compose music for a requiem music for a
mass music for a feast music to
celebrate someone's birthday to
celebrate the king to to the music was
written to integrate into society it you
wouldn't just write unless you were
making studies or maybe you were
studying to practice or you were doing
things like that but what your ultimate
purpose was to write a piece of music
which would which would function you
know even storytelling that's been a
while since we've had that but even
storytelling in a traditional sense like
if you think of the great epics if you
think of the Iliad or the The Odyssey
those were community building stories
those stories were meant to create to
even create what the Greeks were so how
do you judge a piece of art where the
artist themselves doesn't know what the
purpose of the piece of art was what do
you mean how do you likely because
you're saying you can pause it a goal
and then whether or not you achieve that
goal through the art that's a measure of
the arts which not it's not necessarily
what worth you could you could go
further than think that it's just based
on the individuals purpose it's it's a
it's a broader thing than that it's like
if you let say a pizza maker decided you
wanted to make a pizza to taste the way
all pizza makers I'm sure there's a
technical term for you and I apologize I
don't know you're just in your greeting
reason why so let's say a pizza maker
decided he wanted to make a pizza that
tastes bad you know he could do that but
it would probably not be considered
great pizza and that guy would probably
not be considered a good pizza art okay
but in there in that example it's
obvious what the intention of the pizza
it's to be eaten but say someone like
Picasso and he just goes in a room he
doesn't know what he's doing he
organizes his room so now he's like
maybe I'm an interior decorator oh I
just discovered cubism somehow in his
room but he doesn't know what it's for
yeah because he doesn't know what it's
for we also don't know what is for
because the artist was just exploring
and they created something yeah so can
we judge it then because we don't know
its purpose well I think that Picasso
and modern art in general has a has a
destabilizing effect on society and I
think
meant for it to be that so in a way
maybe they did what they did was right
I think that most modern art and
contemporary art it believes in a
revolutionary vision of reality that the
purpose that our purpose is to is to
bring about revolutions to to destroy
the the status quo to destroy the
existing order and and I think that
Picasso was a communist I mean he was a
communist pretty much his whole life
even even when it became embarrassing
maybe to be so and a lot of the a lot of
the modern artists were either communist
or fascists you know these the futurists
were straight on fascists you know they
wanted to burn the old system down and
set up a totalitarian you know system of
art to totalitarian system of art we
have artists who were totalitarian in
their artistic vision we don't we don't
tend to want to see them that way now
for some reason but uh but the a lot of
the the abstract artists were there
especially the Russian abstract artists
had a totalitarian vision of reality and
a lot of modern designers were very
totalitarian you know some some modern
architects would say things like you
know I wish I could design the people in
my house or I wish I could nail the
chairs to the floor so that I could
control something excess order exactly
everything the way the way it is okay
and so you have these these you have
like this you have this these two
tendencies let's say modern art you have
both you have a kind of destructive
tendency and a totalitarian tendency
which is part of the modern world so you
see it as off balance because yeah and
Peter's the praetor Sounion point of
view which is also the Dallas point of
view there's order chaos and you see it
as being on the extremes and that
they're not mediating between the two
properly yeah no I agree I think the
whole modern world that's what it is
it's just a swing it's just this this
pendulum swing between two two excesses
and you can see it in modern art you can
see it as well and they become confused
and they kind of fight and then they
they break each other apart
but but it's a it is a fascinating thing
to see now we kind of just gloss over a
lot of it but if you look at the way for
example that even post abstract
expressionist art let's say manifested
itself it started with this free
you know Jackson Pollock throwing paint
on the ground and and and kind of this
chaotic energy and everything and then
it ended with color field painting where
it was like just strips of one color and
you couldn't do anything else like it
was it was completely everything was
controlled in these extremely tight
tight boxes of what you could do so I
love this painting that was just white
with one speck of red do you know that's
painting I forget it's a mmm large it's
a very famous painting yeah I don't know
which I don't know if any rapport with
that okay just a imagine I'm blank yes I
can imagine there's some Squatch of red
in the corner yeah and it sold for
millions of dollars is that contemporary
yeah well that's it depends it could be
it would probably be a moderate we've
all be considered modern or late modern
you could say Contemporary Arts it tends
to be more cynical and and we'll take
modern conventions and be more playful
about them and we'll create a kind of
parody for example German artists like
Richter who is an abstract artist but
his abstract art is considered to be a
kind of parody of abstract art where
it's a it's almost like a comment on
abstract art it's not directly abstract
art it's it looks like abstract art with
a kind of photo kind of weird photo
lack of focus in it and there's a lot of
neo abstract artists who are actually
there's a kind of weird cynicism to what
they're doing but it gets very confusing
contemporary art right now is just a
giant ball of anything like you it's
very difficult to know there is a most
postmodern or these I think no I think
that we have I think that what I'm doing
is is could be considered
post-postmodern and I'm part of a group
let's say of people who have grown up in
contemporary art who learned
contemporary art several who are who had
a promising contemporary art career
ahead of them you know they had they
were in galleries they had they had
different scholarships and everything to
big schools but then they kind of came
to the end of the kind of say like they
came to the end of the carnival and at
some point the carnival has to end you
know at some point you've eaten enough
pie and you're you know you've had
enough you'd had enough having a pizza
had enough pizza exactly
enough sugar and and and and blinking
lights and so what ends up happening is
a rediscovery of what I would call
traditional art and ice and I see that
you see that so I know several
iconographer who make icons for churches
who had that exact turn where they came
to the end of contemporary art and they
realized this is this is just nihilism
it's just nihilism on steroids and so
they they reimburse let's say the
traditional language of the church some
people that happened within a field of
modern okay so there's modernism there's
post-modernism then there's
traditionalism yeah now does this cycle
happen even within a section so there's
the section of traditional intersection
of modernism and post-modernism or
doesn't happen within I think that I
think I've been as with the sections as
a whole well the problem the problem
with the contemporary art world is that
the very setup of the contemporary art
world is is not conducive for it within
that world for let's say a return to
order to happen or a let's say a post
post modernism to happen because you you
have a return to the proper balance
between order and chaos because as you
were saying caches to be returned to
order because the fascist had extreme
orders right for them it would be
returned to the middle exactly until the
problem is it's true in the modern that
one of the things we forget about
modernism is there is another wing of
modernism which we don't tend to to to
think of which is social realism and
social realism is has been used very
much as a just pure propaganda like just
a pure propaganda tool because it's
whole style its whole affectations are
basically you know a kind of
sentimentality a you know a kind of
going in to get your sense of
nationalism or your sense of courage or
whatever and so they they tend to push
you towards towards propaganda so what
people traditionally think of as
propaganda is social realism I mean
usually those are the twenties a Nazi
propagandist of course yes there and the
same with the same with the Russians
like the Russians had a
whole tradition of social realism I mean
Jordan Peterson has has collected them
he is houses full of social Russian
social realism where that the purpose of
these paintings is to make you a good
citizen right to make you participate in
in in the state do you see the elements
of social realism in the modern films
that we have now like Mona
I think it's called Mona they the one
that you analyze Mona Mona Mona and then
frozen and then Wonder Woman yeah well
right now we we don't I would say that
we're not we're not using social realism
for our propaganda anymore the because
it's a different it's a weird different
it's a weird different world than for
example early century early one of the
things that has happened is let's say
the revolutionary elements of our
society they they've actually understood
symbolism they've been the ones who for
the past let's say 50 years have
understood symbolism the most and so
they've actually been using let's say
mythological structures to affect to you
to affect their propaganda it's very
different times like the Nazi symbol
being swastika was what Corsica was I
mean the swastika is one of the most
ancient images one of the most ancient
symbols that exist it's it's it's an
image that is University could find it
in all cultures yeah you can find it in
you can go to a church medieval church
and see swastikas you can go to a Hindu
temple and see swastikas it is it's
probably one of the oldest images we
have and so they were able to to take it
to change it a little bit they made it
instead of making it straight they
slanted it I think that it's in the
Nazis are a really good example in a way
in the sense that the Nazis they wanted
to co-op mythological thinking more than
others they had a weird they also they
had a weird religious feel to them right
they they had a kind of strange esoteric
and you know the desire to renew to
revive northern gods they also had weird
contacts with with Indian the the the
the aristocracy in India with the what
are the names of the caste I can't
remember they in the caste
so do you think that's one of the
reasons right yeah why these
totalitarian regimes when they come in
particularly on the left so particularly
communist regimes that they want to
obliterate traditional arts and
obliterate religion and ban it over sure
because they understand it well they
because they they understand how potent
it is and also because especially the
Communists the communist groups they
really wanted to because they they
believed that the human person is
malleable right that we're a blank slate
type and so what they they wanted to
destroy the all the cultural tenets
which were there in order to bring about
their utopia you know the Chinese the
Russians did it - Russians liquidated
they destroyed the Russians destroyed
over 30,000 churches just during the the
early times of Stalin and you know we
all know that the Maoist Cultural
Revolution was insane and if you just
went around destroying everything not
only destroying but execute executing
anybody they have to do with the
priesthood yeah and the same thing I
mean more Buddhists really early
communist Russia Russians would go
around you know and just just shoot
priests in the head you know it was it
cruising in same time so it's like
liquidating the the the imagery in order
to bring about their their utopia but
today we today it's weird it's different
our our version of that let's say our
version of propagandas is a little
different from that it's more it's more
insipid and it's more it tends to
understand like I said it tends to be
more subversive rather than directly
offensive in in the sense that it's
better to instead of it's better to show
like the show in versions and to to to
have stories with the notion that the
inverted is becomes the norm in a way
and that seems to be the way to that a
lot of propaganda is happening now and
so it's it's a bit different and so
sometimes it's tricky because sometimes
the stories actually end up looking very
much like ancient traditional stories
it's often just that they're upside down
or that there's a like Trek is a great
example trek is like the most the
easiest example to see where it looks
like a fairy tale but it's actually an
upside down it's a totally upside down
fairy tale where you have older and
older and a princess
you know the ogre is this monster and
they represent him as a monster
that would be an example of a postmodern
film yeah of an upside down fairy tale
of a subversive use of traditional
tropes where all the tropes are there
but they're just totally upside down you
know the ogre is represented as a
monster he suggested it suggests that
he's a cannibal he suggests all these
things that the normal ogre is and then
he meets a princess and in the end the
princess becomes an ogre and it's like
okay how their shape of water is a great
example to recent a more recent version
where all the normative characters you
know the the Christian the the the the
the white male all that they're all
absolutely evil okay and and then all
the kind of exceptional characters like
the monster and then all these other
exceptional categories are somehow pure
and innocent and all of that and then in
the end the the woman becomes them
becomes a monster like that's how it
ends she goes into the water she becomes
a sea monster and it's like we're so
used to it we think that somehow that
that's a normal way for a story to go
but it's very disturbing you know a
normal thing that's so much in the past
15 years yeah a normal story like the
story of the Frog and the princess for
example is that the exceptional
character the Frog is talking frog who's
a monster is by some proof of their vet
virtue integrated into the world right
Little Mermaid becomes a human yeah well
that's a difficult path anyo becomes a
human yeah Ponyo is that yeah that's
that's a good that's a good example you
know Miyazaki I've been watching these
Aki films because you commented on
spirited away and I wanted to watch it
again so I started watching a few and I
was trying to put my finger on why is it
so it's it's a damn good his films are
very good and I realized not only is are
they magical and whimsical like a child
in an imaginative but there's a complete
lack of cynicism yeah complete lack of
sarcasm
yes sarcasm or or sardonic commentary
yeah no that's I think you really put
your finger
and I think that because we're in a
situation because of our because of
Technology and because of our extremely
ordered societies where we have a you
know everything is controlled by the
state basic not everything but so much
of our world is controlled by the state
and by these giant corporations and
everything we have a need for feminine
symbolism we have a need for the private
sphere we have a need for the refreshing
aspect of of our personal relationships
all this feminine symbolism we have a
desire and a need for it and the thing
about Miyazaki is that almost all his
films take on this feminine symbolism
but he does it in such a beautiful way
where he doesn't feel the need to be
subversive or to kind of show how you
know the male character is an idiot or
or as useless there's a complete absence
or lack of a political myth oh ya know I
think the closest maybe pawn yahwah or
he says the humans are ruining the earth
right with their ships that's the
closest that i found so far but i agree
i agree that that's what makes them so
strong and that's why and they make them
so strong also because he's able to
create strong female characters but in a
manner which is not doesn't it doesn't
have that kind of anger and bitterness
and cynicism in it or it's more like a
celebration of these beautiful feminine
character and it doesn't make the
feminine the masculine doesn't put a
sank a girl have traditionally masculine
qualities and then say we're subverting
notions of gender yeah because that's
what i mean that's what so many of the
suit the like the superior moves that
we've seen recently and a lot of that
like the star wars movies and everything
is and i think that's why people are
kind of annoyed with them is because
they're it's not only the desire to make
let's say a feminine care a female
character into the same action hero that
we've had you know since the 1980s and
everybody's criticized like it's you
know it's the feminists or you know the
the postmodern criticized that figure of
the of this of the hero of the male hero
and so but now you want to make a woman
into it masculinity is toxic as long as
it's a male exactly like masculinity
becomes good if it's a female who
embodies it it's it's just completely
it's completely upside down and then
here's what else what else is i find
funny about that
then feminine femininity is just honor
practive when it's attached to a male so
as a male you can't win no if you're in
it if you're a masculine so but if
you're attractive in your toxic met and
you have toxic masculinity you can get
away with almost anything we have never
had this conversation with Janice via
mango that the people who are getting
who are getting sent letters saying stop
what you're doing is are they tend to be
people who are unattractive
yeah males yeah exact track of male than
the woman wouldn't find it cat calling
she would find it no I I totally agree
who's that who's that British comedian
here that Jordan did an interview with
his name this one British comedian he's
I'll oh no no he's he Jordan turned in I
think he was like he's like a huge deal
and he came to press and everything he
did an interview with Sam Harris and he
didn't be with Jordan we he's kind of on
board with it until it until I feel dark
well anyways he was like he was this
super good-looking guy and he was
extremely promiscuous you know and just
had loads and loads of sex all kinds of
women and I saw a Russell Brand yeah
Russell Brett I saw him once meeting
with a woman talking to her and he
reached back behind her back and he
undid her bra like that and everybody
was laughing and she was laughing at you
like oh what did you do it's so funny
hahaha and like really interesting you
know imagine if anybody else had done
that you know what it would have been
and I'm just I mean I'm figuring like
maybe Russell ran at some point I'm
gonna turn on him when he kind of when
he loses is his attractive edge they
might turn on him at some point but yeah
no I agree that it's mostly that that
that certain behaviors let's say trying
to trying to be flirty with a woman if
you're good-looking and you're into your
desirable then that's not a problem but
if you're ugly let's get to Lord of the
Rings
alright Lord of the Rings I want you to
tell me the story of not don't tell me
the story yeah hours and hours tell me
the symbolism behind the ring well the
ring the ring is really power I mean
it's called ring of power but I think
that the ring is the power in the sense
that we understand it today and in the
sense of technological power that is the
capacity to affect the world right so it
could be political as well but a good
way to understand it is is technological
power in the sense that it's it's a it's
the the
the capacity to control to affect things
around you and so the ring itself this
symbol of metallurgy is a very ancient
symbol of exactly that right in the
Bible you have this notion that as the
fall of man kind of increases moving
towards the flood one of the steps is
the creation of met of metallurgy with
tubal-cain
and the forging of weapons but that is
it's there in other traditions as well
and other somebody was telling me a
Nordic tradition about almost the same
idea that the and in Greek in Greek
thinking you know Festus the god of
metallurgy is a he's a he's kind of like
a monstrous deformed God who whose was
kicked out of the the Olympia of Olympus
and lives in a kind of dark firey place
and that's where he makes his and so
it's like this it's kind of like an
image of the capacity on the margin to
to control the the outside you could say
something like that does that make sense
yeah yeah and then you're saying how the
the ring becoming something that makes
you invisible makes sense because right
well the the idea is that you have to
understand it you have to understand
technology or if you have to understand
power or capacity to move out into the
margin you have to understand it as
adding layers to yourself right that's
that's a good way to understand
technology you could don't add the
supplement so you supplement your
existence with something so you know you
wear clothes you add a layer of clothes
because and then you can live further
out right you used to be only to live on
the equator now you can live further out
from the equator because you have
clothes and you can keep warm then you
develop houses you develop develop
different technologies to bolster your
capacity to live further out so imagine
now the same thing in terms of political
power you are one person what can you do
you can't do much so you you you in
becoming an adding power to yourself
let's say you you hire an army you hired
you get weapons you put on an armor you
do all these things you learn to write a
horse you have all these things that you
add to yourself in order to make
yourself more powerful right and the
ultimate example of that is the ornament
so we often don't think what a
metaphysically what an ornament is but
it an ornament is something that you add
to another thing to make it just to make
it different just to make it special
right because it has no purpose if I if
I put up if I paint a flower on a chair
it doesn't participate in the chair
nature of the chair doesn't help me sit
on it it doesn't that's what you know it
all it does is it makes it different
from others and it's the same for people
so so a woman will wear jewelry a man
will wear will will wear Julie as well a
woman will wear makeup in order to to
supplement her beauty you could say so a
woman wears me to supplement her beauty
but what happens is as the supplement
gets stronger and stronger you the
question is are you supplementing to
show right - to call attention to or are
you supplementing in order to hide the
true nature of what it is that you're
supplementing right and it's hard to
know when that happens right it's hard
to know when I take a hammer in order to
be able to hit nails and and and hit
them in but then at some point the
weapon that the technology becomes so
big that it I could never do it like
it's actually there to mask my
incapacity to to do what it that that
actual action and the same with with
makeup you know you everybody has seen a
woman who at some point in their her
life as she enters her 50s or 60s she
doesn't she doesn't realize what's going
on and then she starts to wear too much
makeup and then you realize that it's
actually there to hide her her age it's
not there to to enhance certain sex
accentuate exactly okay and so that's
how the ornament makes you invisible is
you you disappear behind the supplement
at some point so if you if you keep
adding those layers at some point those
layers are all that is it's like icy icy
so okay so an empty shell so there's
technology I'm just gonna
yes see if I understand so there's
technology and use that technology to
expand what you can do to expand your
dominion over the world and over others
yeah then you can also think of it in
terms of makeup as a technology buying a
big car to signal your attractiveness is
a technology in the sense because it's a
tool the tool is another word for
technology right and the big car is a
great is the great example right I mean
for a man that's as that's a that's a
it's a joke that we have right the guy
with the sports car you know is it there
- is it there - actually hide something
about him something that he's missing
some some aspect of him which is
deficient and then he's hiding himself
behind his big car he's actually hiding
the fact that he's I mean this is like
the joke right he's hiding himself the
fact that he's somehow deficient in some
spheres of his love life with this big
car so he's overcompensating in that
manner and so that's a way for him to
hide he's he's hiding himself behind
this this ring there's another work when
it comes to armies like let's say you're
the President of the United States and
you just keep extra mute keep pumping
money into the military so you're
expanding your range of Dominion yeah
how does that relate to hiding um let's
try to understand it in terms of in
terms of an army because I understand it
in terms of masking when it comes to
something like makeup or the man with
the car yeah or someone with extremely
well someone who's extremely well
dressed but to the point of not being
well being overly dressed well I would
say I would say we could see some
examples I think in terms of when is it
that lets say civilizations become
expansive I mean I think a lot of people
could argue with me on on this for sure
okay but I think that if you look at the
the the expansion of the Roman Empire
for example the question is why did it
expand like why why would it expand and
one of the answers could be exactly what
I said it could be exactly that it is
lacking within itself what it needs to
exist and so it has to has to eat has to
speed up how with what it's eating on
the outside it has to kind of devour the
outside it and ad ad ad ad ad ad ad to a
point where it always feels like it it's
it's um it's pushing away that moment
where it's going to break apart by doing
that because it's there's something in
the center which is lacking there's some
there's some inner thing which is
lacking and you see that I mean I think
that we see that in you could think
about in terms of materialism how people
will start to buy buy buy things because
there's something lacking within
themselves and so they do that in a way
to make them feel like they're like
they're still going okay so they like
something crucial that will help them
survive us so they stave off the
inevitable by increasing their
imperialistic powers there's something
that the Communists did I think so I
think that that's a good way to
understand it in terms of of of Empires
that tend to I mean that's one example
because others could just simply be
greed yeah but I think that greed is
that greed is that - I think that this
nah that's true because greed could also
be tied to an insecurity which means you
don't have something that's right and so
that's why the ring is related to our
desires this periphery this idea of
supplement is also related to what the
Christians would call the passions so
you have these you have these things
that pull you from the outside desires
you know gluttony pride sexual desire
all these things and so if if you move
in that direction usually that's what it
is
you're devour your eating your you're
taking in things you're you're acting in
certain ways in order to compensate for
something that you're lacking interior
interior ly you know and everybody knows
someone who does that I mean you can
take extreme cases of someone that say
who drinks you know and you know and you
know someone who becomes an alcoholic he
doesn't just become an alcoholic because
of alcohol right usually you become an
alcoholic you use do you drink to fill
up some malaise that you have some kind
of and everybody has that malaise you
know we just we have different ways of
dealing with it but you you can you
engage in certain supplementary
behaviors in order to and the sample
because the sub line is also medicine
that's also important and understanding
this idea of supplement is it also has
to do with with with the notion of
taking in something or intoxicants or
medicine all that is part of this notion
of the supplement because when you're
sick you have to take something from the
outside in order to heal you and it
works like it can work you know and the
supplement is not there's nothing wrong
about the supplement there's nothing
wrong about this process it's just that
it can become out of control you know
because you need to eat and and there's
nothing wrong with with sexual activity
that all those things are fine it's just
that if you fall you can fall into a a
you can fall into a pattern where that
behavior or that that that desire or or
you know the alcohol or drugs or
whatever it is or power or all the
things that we do or buying cars or you
know whatever it is that we do to
supplement our existence takes you away
from yourself and then you lose yourself
in that you you know you lose yourself
in your in your desires and you you you
cease to you've lost the heart like
you've lost the memory of the heart you
could call it how does this relate to
the ring becoming heavier well I think
that the ring becomes heavier as if you
understand it as let's say Frodo is
moving out into that chaotic world and
so it has to become heavier in a certain
way just like you need to add more and
more layers the further away you get
from yourself so it's it's going to be
you know it's like you haven't need a
bigger bigger gun a bigger sword a
bigger you know a bigger army a bigger
house of you know more technology you
going out into space is the ultimate
example you know like you go out into
space you need a massive shell around
you a massive massive shell to protect
you from the outside because the outside
will kill you and and I think that
that's what that's what's happening in
the Lord of the Rings is that as Frodo
is moving away from his home as he's
moving away from his family his identity
and all of that and he's moving out
towards this this dark place then his
the ring gets heavier and it takes a
toll on him you know at first he has
enough innocence to to bear the ring
without being
taken over but as he moves out and
further and further and further out then
it starts to to eat away at him you know
and the only character in Lord of the
Rings who can handle the ring without a
problem is his Tom Bombadil and that's
because he is a representation of that
natural kind of innocence that kind of
boisterous self fullness of being you
know he doesn't he doesn't he's a he's a
he has a kind of joyful innocence that
means that he's not tempted by the the
the the the periphery are tempted by
that a good example is in the movie
spirited away it's a great example where
the the central character what is her
name again forget her name anyways the
this sin but that was what she was given
yeah
well sin she she herself has that
innocence and so when when she's she's
not in danger the same way that others
are in that world of gold and of
pleasures and of you know this this this
this house of kind of sensuality she's
not she's not in danger so when the when
the monster when no face presents her
with the gold she's like huh but she'll
take it if she needs it right and it's
fine psycho she needs she needs that she
needs something from no fate she'll take
it she's fine but then he's like no I
want to give you more want you give him
more and she's like why would I want
more I I'm fine
I I needed this tool to do this and I
did it and then I'm done and that's
because she was innocent I think it's
because she has she had a a kind of
innocence in the right way to see
innocence a kind of purity you could say
a kind of lack of self I tell you a a
joyful purity I would I don't know how
else to say it yeah we were talking
about the Little Mermaid before we
started filming and I don't know if you
had much time to think about it before
we started filming but can you comment
on how the Little Mermaid has a
connection to today right well
especially if if you're talking about
the movie The Little Mermaid like the
Disney
we I think it's it's interesting because
the Little Mermaid she it's funny
because maybe I need to make a caveat
about about the Little Mermaid the first
Little Mermaid like the one that was
written by Hans Christian Andersen was
really about the incapacity to cross
over it was it was a it was really about
the be happy with what you are because
she dies right she can't she can't cross
over into the human world because that's
not her place right and so the Disney
version is the actual total opposite the
Disney version is the very opposite it
is the it is the modern like you can be
whatever you want
version of that so it's very it's kind
of interesting to first of all to think
about the difference between the two
worlds the worlds of Hans Christian
Andersen and and our world today where
we have this idea that you can pretty
much just do whatever you want but it
what's interesting in in the the that's
the scene with the the witch what's her
name again
Ursula Ursula yeah what is interesting
in that scene is that Ursula is making
her feel like she cares about her right
making her feel like she's this poor
this poor thing this poor victim of her
circumstance this poor and she's like
I'm going to I can offer you what you
want I can offer you your desire but
what you have to give me is is your
voice is your self basically and so in a
way locals yeah exactly your logos and
so in a way it is it is an image of this
problem of desire in that sense and the
problem with that movie is that in the
end she gets her thing that's the
problem it's like if that's a bit of
that that's more complicated but but but
she's like you need to sacrifice your
self your logos in order to get what you
desire you know and that's that is part
of this notion of the supplement in a
sense is that you you if you if you
desire this new car that's what you
really desire if you if you desire to to
have all these sexual experiences if you
desire to have a
lifestyle and that's like that's what
you think that that's what you are
that's when you lose your logo that's
interesting because you can look at it
from two points of view one is Ursula
which you can think of as the radical
left enticing people with with wish
fulfillment I just want your voice but
then on the other side there's the
people who are willing to give up their
voice yeah we're willing to to give up
there there's their logo so they're it's
their core their heart or whatever in
order to get something that they desire
in order to get something that they want
and I think that that's you know and
there's something about that in the ring
- there's something about that in the
notion of the ring in general where you
know the person who is going to bear the
ring especially someone who already has
a purpose that that they're they're
going to be able to accomplish what they
want like if they have that power
they'll be able to do that but they kind
of have to give up have to kind of give
up their soul to to get it and it's a
magical and all the magical transactions
in stories are always kind of like that
it's like you know you you get what you
want but you have to give up something
more profound in order to to get that
and we and I think then you see it you
see people who go through that all the
time people go through that all the time
right they the the guy who who all he
wants is to get his million dollars and
then he sacrifices his family sacrifices
his relationship with his wife he
sacrifices the things that are actually
very precious that are really precious
because they constitute your your being
in terms of a communal being and they do
that to get what they want and I think
that in terms of the radical left one of
the problems that we're seeing is that
the radical left has been able to
convince people that there are only this
one aspect of what they want and so
someone is like I you know I feel like
I'm you know that that I either I'm just
one thing like I'm just one thing and if
I embrace this one aspect of myself I
will get power like I'll get some
political power and I think that that's
that's dangerous in terms of just normal
people like as a we're not like I am NOT
just a a you know I'm not just a man I'm
not just a
Carver I'm not just a or if I was a if I
was gay I'm not just gay I'm not just
trans I'm not just whatever and I'm not
just a European I'm not so it's like if
you embrace this one aspect of yourself
then all of a sudden it's like but it
there's something that's how you make a
weapon right that's what a weapon is a
weapon is a point it's like I'm gonna
push something into a point then I'm
gonna use it as a weapon and that's how
you make a weapon but that's not the way
you make a person right you don't make a
person by turning a person into into a
weapon or weaponizing you know something
about yourself because you lose yourself
into that into in that and that weapon
you could say and you can do it with all
kinds of things but you can you can you
could turn your bitterness into that you
could become your bitterness can become
your bitterness and your parents you
know you hate your parents because of
what they did and your whole life falls
into that bitterness and you make this
nice jagged pointy thing where you all
you exist in is this one thing about you
which is the way your parents treated
you and you've you-you-you dive into
that it becomes your your spear and you
you start slashing at the world with it
and it makes you feel powerful because
it works it actually does give you power
but you lose something and in there and
the balance you lose the capacity to
become a full person the total being hmm
I just had a thought about about giving
up what you have in order to get what
you want which is Ariel but nihilists in
today's world give up what they want in
order to keep what they have so they
don't want they'll give up their
aspirations like forget about marriage
even though they actually want it forget
about forget about traditional values
even though they actually want friends
and they would like maybe a nuclear
family or whatever it may be in order to
retain their worldview what they have
but I think it has to do also with a a
kind of shortening of not when nihilism
tends to do is it tends to shorten the
the horizon you could say and so the
most immediate things we have are these
desires right those are the most
immediate the idea of of wanting a
family you have to you have to like swim
over that first wave which is I just
want to have a beer right you have to
swim over that and
to get to something which is more
purposeful and so I think that when
nihilism does is it it opens up the
possibility of just living in more
immediate desires you know playing video
games all day or whatever it is that you
want to do in the immediate and not feel
like you have to to direct yourself
towards something which is higher and so
in that sense I think that that's what
that's what niala intends to do to
people so what do the hostile brothers
Cain and Abel there are others which I
can't think of right now but what do
they have to tell us about our current
situation with regards to the radical
after even the Hulk right
yeah well I think in terms of I think in
terms of Cain and Abel
I really do i do think that Jordan
Peterson has hit the nail on the right
place in terms of that story and how it
relates to today in the sense of
resentment and I think that in the story
of Cain and Abel especially you see Cain
who feels like he should have more than
what he has and it's not just and so it
becomes the basic you could say that
it's pride right pride is the is the
first sin it's the first sin in pretty
much all of the whole biblical story you
know the devil sin is pride Cain's sin
is pride Adam and Eve sin is pride as
well it's it's the feeling that I
deserve more than what what I should
have and it's always relative to someone
else because it's not it's almost
equivalent to I should have more but
also you shouldn't have that if I don't
have that you shouldn't have oh yeah for
sure no I totally agree and I think that
that's it seems to be I think that
that's that's for sure if you talk to
people who are far on the Left far on
the left you could say you doesn't take
a long time to scratch at the fact that
what frustrates them is not so much that
they're poor because most of the time at
least here they're not you know you know
there's very few people starving in
Canada I mean I'm sure there are but
they're very few it's usually that
they're annoyed to think of Jeff Bezos
in his you know his huge house and
that's what that's what annoys them
and I think that I mean I'm not saying
that there isn't something to say for
the problem of disparity and the problem
of people of one person having too much
power I think that that's something
which is important to think about and to
talk about where where certain
individuals have so much power that they
be actually weakened to become a danger
to social cohesion but but I think that
if it's if you look at it out of
resentment in the sense like you know
why why would he why is why does he
where would he get that and why why not
me you know it's not fair that kind of
thinking I think that doesn't lead the
person in a in a good situation and if
you see it in the sort of cane of course
is where he ends up killing his brother
because because he in in store cane
what's interesting in that story is that
it doesn't tell you doesn't tell you why
it's really it's really fascinating
because later traditions have always
tried to like to try to guess why why is
it that cane sacrifice was not
acceptable to God but in the story
itself it doesn't say it just says cane
sacrifice is not acceptable table
sacrifice is acceptable it's like okay
you don't even know why and so but it
doesn't matter it's like that's reality
right another way to see it is this is
these are the cards that have been dealt
you this is it you can't argue with
reality and so are you going to argue
with reality are you going to say I
should have more and and I'm gonna want
more so much as I'm willing to blow the
whole thing up just because I don't have
what I want
you know and and I think that what you
see what you're seeing in the especially
in the in there and the radical left is
you definitely see that type of that
type of think and you see it to like
like you said you do see it now in the
extreme right you're seeing similar
things as well where there there is a
nihilism which is propping up in the
more extreme right which is you know
basically our culture Western culture is
is over so let's just participate in and
blowing it up like let's just let's just
run it into the ground you know so no
one can have it so there's a little bit
of that going on and it's very
disturbing to watch so you
something that I always struggle with is
the radical left inside there isn't
there is there is a grain of truth more
than a grain of truth which is that we
don't all have what we want which will
never all have what we want but there's
some basic needs so in Canada we all
have health care so let's just forget
about let's say in the States so they
don't all have health care they don't
all have they all are many people are
living paycheck to paycheck
and then they look at someone like Jeff
Bezos and they say it's not fair that
someone should be living so insouciantly
and free while I am just struggling yeah
okay so there is something to be said
about not having to struggle this much
for basic necessities then at the same
time there is something to be said of
well are you trying to be a champion for
the cause of people who are struggling
or are you just trying to tear down
those who have much more than you now
there is something there is also
something to be said for again tearing
down those who have disproportionately
too much simply because we don't want
power to accumulate in the hands of the
few and in crony capitalism capitalism
obviously money translates into politics
and we don't want that so the it's
there's I see both sides and I'm always
struggling because I see the benevolent
side of the radical left edges riches
which is the benevolent side of the left
in general yeah and then obviously the
benevolent side of the right comes out
as well which is what we need
hierarchies you can't just dispense with
all hierarchies okay what for what do
you what is it that you struggle with
you struggle with so I think that the
left the lack of any attempt to
criticize the radical left they can just
say no it's not this claim of resentment
it's that all that nice bonhomie
gracious altruistic philanthropic aspect
all those at all those elements that you
just listed that's that's actually our
true motivation yeah and it's difficult
well you can look you can take the
psychoanalytical approach which is
something I'm going to try to do in the
documentary which is well what do your
behavior so forget about what you say
yeah let's see how you act so are you
killing tens of millions of people and
that in the 1900s all obviously they
didn't but I'm saying you the same
philosophy right has and are you
clapping when Jordan Peterson is
debating spa boy
jezic says says jezik and Jordan
Peterson references bloody violent
revolution and then the rest and then
the radical left says yeah which
happened I don't know if you saw I saw I
saw the one where he says he says
hierarchies are not he says hierarchies
are not all posited on on violence and
dispossessing and everything and then
someone laughs and I thought his his
answer was so perfect he said I said
well maybe those that laugh is that's
the way they would do it there's another
time where he just mentioned what would
happen is bloody violent revolution and
then the father's here yeah people
haven't taken it back yeah he didn't
know what to say well yeah how would you
know to say to that because I mean I
think and those people have never
experienced anything close to bloody
violent revolution like I was so
furthest documentary I started looking
at clips of just-just-just the worst
some of the worst of what humans can do
to other humans on a large scale and and
it just it just tears you apart man like
some of them are not that visceral
because there's black and white footage
with no sound yeah there's still and
then some are like the what the Tamil
Tigers what the single Lee's government
did to the Tamil Tigers and then you see
mothers holding their children and their
children just screaming because there's
bombs being dropped on them ahead and
they don't know if they're gonna and
they die and and it's just feared if
you're in fear breaks your heart and
that's what a violent revolution is like
yeah no I think that I think especially
now you know it's it's so I think that's
what's difficult is that you know you
can imagine that someone in the 19th
century just coming out of very
difficult in like let's say differed
very difficult times in Russia where
you're present you're barely eating you
don't get to eat any meat all your
socratis eat meat you know like that
kind of life where it's very it's very
difficult and then that you would feel
so desperate that you would be willing
to to risk everything you know just to
topple the whole thing yeah compared to
now which is like I mean who are these
people like who want bloody revolution
in our
in our country I mean I got 1% of
anybody who's right and I so I don't
understand like I don't I don't totally
understand how that and I also don't
understand this how they define what
rich is because rich to me always seems
to be defined by them as whoever is
richer than me
exactly no no I agree I agree yeah yeah
so what other ancient stories have you
read yeah that applied to this modern
time
radical left Albright's crazy world that
we live in
um I was thinking about that and and I
don't and I don't I don't totally see in
terms of we seem to be in a very unique
moment because one of the things that's
happening right now which is which is
extremely unique is that we have these
two excesses that are growing up at the
same time and I think that that's the
one thing that people find very
difficult to see because they tend to
just see the other excess right and so
for example we live in a world where
there's more control and more
calculation of what you're doing and any
other time in the history of the world
right Google has everything about you
right you exist virtually in Google's
some Google Drive there you know
everything about you you know everything
you've said everything you've thought
pretty much they can call you from here
because basically clone you from your
email and your your behavior it's not
you email it's your behavior online
which you click here which they they
have these gigantic algorithms which
calculate and they know like where you
are what you're interested in you know
there are crazy stories of people who
who you know like with a girl who is
looking online for certain things not
related to pregnancy but they've
calculated that if you look online for
certain things even if it's not directly
related to pregnancy it probably means
you're pregnant and so they'll show you
ads for pregnancy stuff right so there's
this massive data control over what we
aren't just in terms of laws like that
the modern state no I can't I can't
build something in my yard I need to get
permission from my town to be
anything I want like I can't right now
we're in the process in Quebec where the
government wants to we're homeschooling
our kids and the government wants to to
force us to take standardized tests
anything that's normal
like I think it's normal that the
government decides what your kids are
going to learn we think that sort of we
think that the government has that
possibility so we have the most but we
also have this weird carnivalesque crazy
world that passions we're you know
pornography is rampant where people are
are people are dying from from from
opioids and so there's also this other
weird world that's completely chaotic
and upside-down so we have these two
things that are kind of growing up at
the same time and so it's almost like
this is a very unique moment in history
where the capacity for absolute control
and the capacity for absolute breakdown
seem to be looking at each other and
somehow feeding into each other so it's
it's very weird I don't know if there's
a certain are there any biblical stories
my brother would probably be better at
finding at finding a story that shows as
much the two extremes at the same time I
mean it's possible that maybe the
closest thing we have would be the
collapse of of the Roman Empire maybe
they could then click the collapse of of
the first collapse with a third surge
third century collapse where it's as if
there was this huge gigantic
bureaucratic state crazy but then this
these decadent elites that were all they
cared about were their orgies and then
it's like it just couldn't couldn't hold
and so it's like it collapsed into civil
war so it seems like maybe that's the
closest thing that we have to
understanding kind of we're like the
symptoms of our society seems to be seem
to be close to let's say that that first
fall they're the second because there's
so much wisdom in these old stories and
if we want to if we want to engineer a
solution to our current times it's
always good to look back and see what
what did they do then yeah you know I
don't think there's a solution to our
current time
III wish I wish and a lot of people you
know and I think that that's one of the
reasons why I kind of took on Jordans
way of seeing things in terms of the
solution a lot of people have criticized
me just for for kind of coming too close
to Jordan as a Christian and a lot of
people have criticized your dn't for his
with his individualism you could say and
I've been thinking about it a lot
recently and I think that I think that
Jordans solution is the only one right
now not individualism in the sense of
not the Iran's right exactly nah see Ayn
Rand kind of selfish individual but the
notion that the in a world that is so
extreme right now and the systems are so
big you know the only thing you can do
is is become a saint right sit as much
as possible is to become adjust in the
world to be to be an anchor for for
people around you and so and that means
changing yourself that means and I think
it is in line with the deepest Christian
teaching which is you know take take the
the beam out of your own eye before
before removing the straw out of your
brother's eye and I and there's also
several citations of science for example
since Seraphim of Sarov who said acquire
the spirit of peace and thousands around
you will be saved and so this notion of
becoming something rather than trying to
to immediately want to to find these
gigantic solutions to the problem
because I don't I think it I think I
think we're headed for trouble and I
think that the only the only hope is
that there will be enough bastions of
civility and and justice and and truth
to to carrying us through right to carry
us through the the chaos because I doubt
to be honest I don't see I don't see us
fixing this for these massive problems
the two-bit are so big it's like it's
like the a I think you know you have all
these people saying be careful about AI
be careful about AI but the no one's
going to stop it's just this
this machine is turning and turning and
speeding up and we're heading towards it
everybody knows we're heading towards it
everybody's afraid everybody knows how
dangerous it could be but no one can
stop it
you know Elon Musk can't stop it no one
can stop it it's gonna happen and so I
don't know sorry to be a pessimist so
where do you see going you just see it
remaining and then we strengthen
ourselves as individuals becoming a a
person that someone can rely on an
anchor I think that now I think that it
has I do think that it has to build
ground up that for sure and I think that
we need we need to rediscover our Center
our heart like we need to rediscover
that and then we also need to
participate in actual communities and
that's one of the reasons why I tell
people that oh you mean to say to say
that it you don't see it going away the
problem of the extreme right and extreme
left with some large scale solution you
see it as a problem that will be solved
from a bottom-up approaches you they can
only be I think it can only be solved by
a bottom-up approach it's the same
problem with with the ecological problem
the ecological problem it's too big
because it's based in people's desires
the the problem the ecological problem
is based on our desire to accumulate and
to to have to have to supplement our
existence to that extent so the problem
is so profound that no matter what what
no matter what recycling you set up it's
not going to go away it's not going to
go away the only thing that can make it
go away is for transform people and
transform communities but we don't like
communities we they don't exist anymore
we don't have communities some some do
but it's it's very different we are this
is why John Revathi faced the current
meeting crisis he's he says well he
might say because it's complicated man
they might say that the extreme radical
left extreme extreme alright are
symptoms of a deeper meaning crisis and
this meeting crisis dates back to the
Year 1200 yeah for sure I totally agree
I when he said 12 century I was like
John you got it that that's where it
started that's where all the the West
started to to vacillate let's say
between extremes and and so it's it's a
it's a cyclical thing it's a story
that's too big for us it's too big for
individuals to think that they're going
to change it but there are ways to exist
in those times of breakdown like there
are ways to exist which alleviate let's
say or make you not be an actor in the
breakdown and henceforth not be an actor
in your own breakdown not not fall and
and and live a life a dissolute life of
the passions and be complete taken up by
your desires and then wake up on your
deathbed and it's like okay I have a big
house in a big car but I'm divorced and
my kids hate me and it's like that's
okay congratulations you know what did
you accomplish and so one of the reasons
why I've insisted a lot of people
sometimes they wonder why I I insist on
it so much is one of the reasons why I
keep saying that at least in the West we
need we need to remember the Christian
story like we need to remember the fact
what it is that made us something yeah
remember also means understanding yes
and part I think it it needs a certain
extent participate in too and so that's
why I take her vacuum idea yeah but I
think we don't we don't fall in the same
place because so John's way of
participation is very individualistic
and so he says I'm a practitioner I
practice this I practice that you know I
I practiced these different mystical
practices and it's like for him it's a
way out of the meaning crisis but it has
to has to come together to we have to
remember that even in Buddhist in in
Buddhist teaching that you say there's a
lack of community in John's I think so I
think so and I think the lack of
community is we don't we don't totally
decide what story we're part of a keep
telling people that people it's
difficult for people to fully understand
it my the way that I view how things are
going on is I think what we're seeing is
playing out of in the West you know
we're seeing up playing out of the
Christian story the bass of Christian
story part of that story is a
breakdown it's there in the story you
know that's why you're the only person
that I've seen articulate our current
crisis in this manner that Christianity
itself might have to die in order for it
to come back again born but I think it's
it's there in the story like it's there
it's there that's interesting because
you're applying the narrative to the
narrative yeah that's how symbolism
works so symbolism is a is a you know
it's embedded structures within
themselves where I did it say that the
archetype is so true that it applies to
the archetype well then it's a it's like
yes exactly
that's a that's also that's what
religious stories do in general like
they they're they can they understand
how they understand a form of
self-consciousness they have a form of
self-consciousness where they try to
look at themselves as well there's it
the weird circularity that's part of the
of the symbolic structure I find that I
find that fascinating I need to think
about that some more because it's an
interesting idea how it hurts someone
else
express it at least not articulated in
the in the direct manner that you yeah
so how did you start to come to view
stories in this symbolic fashion so
you're saying you're 22 or you just
graduated from college and your teacher
was telling you you don't belong here
yeah you're a traditionalist the
questions you're asking are are not ones
that you'll find an answer to not in
college
yeah well so what basically happened is
I I tried to make contemporary for a
little while I had a studio with some
friends and you know I was kind of
working towards something and then this
are freelancers for some what like a
real artist like go into a gallery and
do it do do they do the real artist
thing you know I made these giant you
know kind of really ego ego-driven giant
giant works of art you know their whole
life is just one big guy so anyway so
that's what I had and then I I got
married and married really kind of
slammed me against myself Frank I saw
all my own flaws Florida's insecurities
and passions and and unreasonableness
and all that just kind of came flying
back can you explain how that happens
because I'd recently got married I don't
want to know I wanna know the story it
depends on people
some people some people get married in
and then it's wonderful for a little
while and then it then then the mirror
starts to show for me it was the
opposite like we got married like a week
after we got married all of a sudden it
was like could you see both of us could
just see so our first year marriage was
hell like it was it was the opposite oh
yeah it was absolute hell like we once
we got through the first year of
marriage week we're like huh never get
worse than that so it's pretty good
let's keep going ha and so so Abbi it
depends on people that's how it was for
us did you live together beforehand no
and so it so it was like that just
seeing this mirror and so it led you to
a lot of questioning and and and also
just kind of spiritual crisis in general
I was also becoming very disillusioned
with the world the kind of the
evangelical world that I was in in
college I'd read a lot of authors a lot
of philosophers and I just felt like the
church where I was going wasn't just
wasn't answering the questions what kind
of church was it I was kind of a Baptist
Baptist evangelical Baptist Church kind
of American style Church they're not
liturgical you know just very kind of
looks like a business meeting can you
explain what you mean when you say
liturgical do you mean to say I know the
surgical means that it's that it has a
service which is which is a pattern
right it's it's based on it's not just a
so it's like it's a evangelical church
today they'll get together they'll sing
songs and they'll have a sermon but
they'll say things like we can do it we
can do whatever like we you know there's
no doesn't matter what you do no
structures in those no actions for your
life no structure for the structure for
the meetings right no structure for the
church and so liturgical means that
there's an order of service and so
there's we we do things in a certain
order like the Jehovah's Witnesses I
don't know if you're familiar with them
yeah well more like more like so the
surgical is like Anglican Catholics
Orthodox they're liturgical so they sing
they they have a the building that's the
architecture of the building is
meaningful the order of the service is
meaningful the
way that the priest is dressed is
meaningful everything is is done in a
manner which is meaningful and which is
which which manifests what you're trying
to do right it's not just not just
arbitrary so so anyway so I wasn't sorry
we're going to a kind of evangelical
church and I felt like he was just
lacking in in profundity lacking and
needing and and also you know I was
reading philosophers and I started
reading authors from other traditions
Buddhist authors Sufi authors and I
discovered mystical the mystical way you
could say this mystical thinking and
transformational thinking you could call
it and I was really impressed by by it
and then I thought whoa I said why is it
that Christians don't have that like why
is it the Christians don't have a
mystical mystical transformations and
mystical vision of how the world works
and and all of that and and it was only
because it did it just I didn't know
about it and then I that's when I
discovered the early church fathers and
traditional Christianity and then
iconography so can you define what I
cannot Rafi is so iconography would be
let's say a way of practicing art which
is traditional in the sense that it has
certain types certain typology it has a
set of rules kind of like if you write a
sonata right do you have certain rules
and then you you write within those
rules so iconography is the visual
practice of the ancient church which was
developed let's say if you went into a
church in the year 1000 or 1100 anywhere
in the world you would have seen pretty
much the same thing and that was done
without a top-down a you know imposition
of what was going to be there but it was
just this kind of bubbling like a brand
style guy for the church know what you
know her brand Styles okay so when you
design a website or or you have a
company that use these fonts use these
colors make sure that when you place the
logo you place it this much of a
distance between the borders well I
don't think no I don't think that's the
way to see it the way to see it is to
see it more like a a vision of you
of the world as full of meaning and full
of pattern and so the story of the world
and the story of our lives is a is a
pattern it's not arbitrary it's not
random and so that pattern then can be
found that say in Scripture can be found
and then it it transposes itself into
the way that we worship let's say so the
structure of how we worship in a church
in a traditional Church he is patterned
based on the same patterns as that you
find in the in the Bible so there's a
center right there's the the altar and
then that's the most holy place and then
you can imagine a series of layers as
you move out from that holy place
remember when I told you a little bit
about this idea of adding layers well
you can see that also in the terms of
sacred space where you have profaned
space which is outside the church and as
you move in to the church then you you
you move towards the sacred center which
is that which defines the space itself
and which defines the community which
defines everything so that structure
let's have an architecture of a church
then in iconography you have those same
types of structures so you have to know
the types it's like you have to
understand that the reason why Christ is
represented in a certain way is not
arbitrary it's there to show you what
who Christ is and so there's certain
manner in which you represent a figure
to show you who what they are and what
their places in this bigger pattern and
then they do this consciously like they
knew that they were not copying or
imitating but that this specific
representation of Christ was being
repeated in other parts of the world do
they know that consciously that here's
the proper representation of Christ or
here's what it's saying we're at the
center because this is what's most holy
and then here's what's profane in the
way that you're articulating it yeah but
I think it's a mix I think it's a mix of
intuition and participation in the life
of a community where we agree on certain
things that we participate in this story
and so for example like if you would ask
me would it be conscious to put Christ
in a central space and you would say
well yeah
but at the same time what else are you
gonna put there because that's the
center that's the incarnation that's the
point where heaven and earth meet that's
the that's the the focus of of the
origin of Christianity the focus of
Christianity so it's like where else
would you put it there's another reason
for the cross and something I've been
thinking about the other reason for the
cross to be symbolized like this is
because this represents the spiritual
and this represents the profane the
mundane earthly and the proper places to
be at both but then the other reason why
the earthly is a little bit higher is
because it's more important to be
slightly more spiritual than you are
earthly I mean yeah I've never thought
about the second part that you said for
sure the cross the cross is meant to
represent the union of heaven and earth
that's for sure and I think that a lot
of people resist that because they say
no that's the shape of a actual cross
right that's how it crosses made of
multiple meanings it's like that's the
thing is that symbolism is not similar
them is the coalescence of things it's
not a it's not just because it's a it's
that's how crosses were made doesn't
mean that it doesn't also mean that
especially in this context that doesn't
come to mean that
and there's also preponderance of things
that are associated with Christ and why
would we choose the cross well there's
obviously obvious reasons why we would
choose the cross yeah but the cross as a
symbol means Moulton Howes multiple
meanings yes and it does it definitely
as a center that's for sure and and if
you look at the early church fathers
they'll say things like you know the
cross is everywhere you know look at the
boat mast you know a mast of a boat with
the sail that's a cross and they'll
point to crosses which exists almost
naturally in the world and say this is
you know the image of the Cross has been
shown forever you know people need to
just recognize what it's talking about
like what is this centre what what's at
the center actually like what does unite
heaven on earth you know that's the
question and that's that's and of course
Christians answer with the Incarnation
that's the that's the answer
but iconography is basically
understanding the rules and the language
of Christian art why it's why it's
resembles what it does and then it's
almost like an algebra and so you know
that the terms then you can if you need
to improvise and
you can but to improvise that image
needs to be done within the general from
his tenants that iconography offers you
you know so it's a it's a truly
traditional truly traditional art in
that sense okay so you started studying
iconography because you were your eyes
were opened yeah as we started studying
Buddhism and you realize they have an
interesting way of seeing the world yeah
what it was it was a lot
it wasn't Buddhism it was a little bit
of Buddhism a lot of Sufi authors I read
some some early modern kind of Sufi
converts and Devi subió Sufi is a
mystical Islam yeah it's a it's a branch
of Islam which is which is far more
mystical analogical and it's closer
some people argue with me if I say this
but it's closer to Christianity in in
some respects because it because of its
emphasis on love and because its
emphasis on on transformational on the
transformation of the person all of that
to get you it's more hot water yeah you
already are do you fundamentally see
Islam as a religion of peace that I
think that we need to see okay we need
to see Islam for what for what Islam
actually says and so religion Islam is a
religion the two spheres in Islam
there's the there's the the sphere of
peace and there's this fear of war and
Islam is the religion of peace in the
sense that within Islam is peace and
that's how that's how its viewed in the
Muslim world unless well that's how it's
been presented and so you have the
outside world which is the space of war
and you have the inside of Islam which
is the space of peace and one of the
goals of Islam is to to to bring peace
to bring the space of peace to the world
but that's why by becoming very kind
Muslim or or by submitting to Islam
somehow by becoming a demi or you know
my paying the tribute and that's it I
mean a lot of Muslims don't think that
today a lot of I mean I would say that
most Muslims in the West don't don't
don't have that approach to Islam
anymore
but traditionally that's what Islam
that's why Islam is a an expansive has
was from the beginning and expansive
religion you know Judaism is not
expansive Judaism is is wants to recover
the Holy Land like they just want their
they want to get their their their plate
without it does that does cause trouble
obviously we see that it's caused
trouble since they're there back there
it's a difficult situation but in
Christianity it's it's kind of not clear
you know because the Roman Empire
converted to Christianity so then the
Roman Empire became Christian and so
it's complicated to think it's not so
much that then Christians went out and
at least in the first you know thousand
years went out to in invaded other
places although it probably happened
you know you get stories in the West you
get stories of you know Charlemagne
converting by the sword and you get
those stories as well but they're always
kind of iffy but Islam is like all
Salaam exploded became huge if you look
at an image of the map at the year 1000
you know it's it's it's immense and so
yeah so I mean I don't know I think that
most Muslims today are not especially
people who come here and depends from
where they come from and what intentions
they have you know in Quebec here a lot
of the muscles who come here come from
northern Africa and they you know they
want to work they want to have a good
life they want to have a good family
they want to to be left alone and do
their thing and yeah so okay so let's
get back to you were studying studying I
can iconography and that allowed you to
see the world and see stories through a
particular lens yes I was watching you
give an interview I mean I was watching
you have a conversation about the
spider-verse with someone yeah and that
person then made a comment about some
others some other aspect of the
spider-verse then you said oh and what
that could mean is this this this and
this and then the guy said oh I didn't
see that before and then you said oh I
didn't see it before until you mentioned
it and that made me realize you
that's not something you've thought
about because for a regular person a
regular person who's even watching this
they would have to sit and think okay
what could the spider-verse mean to
here's what I know
okay okay hmm okay this fits in here
this fits in here this doesn't work okay
okay and then would take them maybe 20
minutes
to come up with something that you came
up with in a in the span of a sentence
or two which means you actually see the
world or you thought about it for so
long that it's just second nature to you
yeah and I want to know how did that
develop and how do you see the world so
do you see people walking down the
street differently than you used to
and no I mean that seriously because
even people who study physiology they
can tell people's ailments just by
watching them walk even if they look
like they're normal oh you you slightly
tilt in this direction so it's almost
like Sherlock Holmes and so you see
people moving towards the subway and
then you think okay that's that's a
place of communion where people don't
interact that's almost like what we had
in the 12th century when this happened
and this happened so I want to know do
you see the world like that no I see I
and how did you start to see yeah okay
the ways I mean I think I see the world
through patterns that's for sure okay
now when you say patterns I'm gonna get
specific here so when you say patterns
you mean repetitions parts yeah of life
the repeat or parts of life that are
abstracted so for example there's a
pattern of talking or I talk you talk I
talk you talk now that's a pattern
okay so repeating or another pattern is
is you abstract out from a certain set
so there's a pattern of what it means to
be human
right so it's I would say okay so the
pattern you could say the pattern starts
with how things exist right and when I
say how things exist what I mean is how
they exist phenomenologically not in
terms of science because that's what
confuses me in terms of experience terms
of experience how we experience things
existing and that's really the basis of
how things exist no matter what we say
like we we tried to push beyond the
phenomenological but we always see it
through the lens so the scientist even
though he has all the scientific
categories he's still in a consciousness
and looking at the world through that
consciousness and or she he or she he or
she yeah just just don't send any
letters and so the the way that
something frees I'll give you a perfect
example so the way that something exists
you need for something to exist to have
it have an identity right and then have
a you could say a variety say it that
way
you need to have an identity and in a
variety or a oneness and a multiple miss
to it are you doing an example well so
if I have a so I have a cup so this has
an identity and it's let's say its
identity is is the cup that's part of
their has I it has other identities but
let's use that one first for start so it
has an identity it's a cup but then it
also it also is not just there's no such
thing as a cup it's actually non-binary
that's offended that you can find it
there's no such thing as there's no pure
cup right not in the world right so a
cup has to have it has to have a
particular particularity to it okay
right and the particularity to it is its
variety it's a multiplicity and then in
order for it to a particularity then it
has to embody other identities so that's
a color it has you know it has to have a
color right but there's no color in the
cup cup doesn't have color but it has to
have color for so there's there's the
concept of cup miss which doesn't
actually exist in the world in space and
time but it's a concept nonetheless
accompanists something that makes up
thank you
essence it's a to Caza I try not to get
too tied up and because people say okay
you replay tonic just trying to see how
things come to to exist and so so
there's an aspect of it which is one
there's an aspect of it which is
multiple and everything always has to to
to have that for anything to exist has
to be one and multiple at the same time
because it also has to be constituent
constituted by parts so you're saying
the elements of this that are not a cup
are but also for even for it to be a cup
it also needs to be consistent to 'td
with parts so it has one oneness then
also has parts which are multiple and
what the companies of the cup holds the
cup together right so let's just say
that you have one and one in many is
that okay okay so if you have one in
many just that yeah you already have a
basic pattern and then you could
look at the world through one in many
and you can notice when things move
towards one and when they move towards
many or how they move towards one how
they move towards many okay so then
let's do that in space you a good way to
represent it in space best way to
represent his face Center periphery so
you have a wheel let's say you have a
center the center is that which around
everything else turns and then as you
move out from the center you get more
quantity you would say as you move
towards the center you get more quality
and so that's a basic pattern so you can
look at a person like that that's that's
extremely interesting you could also
look at the political sphere like that
yeah would you say the radical left is
on the periphery and then the alt-right
is in the extreme center um I struggle
with this old right thing but let's talk
about the right cuz I talked about the
radical radical left so let's say the
left so you let's say right hand left
hand we could use that okay so right the
right hand traditionally really this is
I'm not making this up the right hand
traditionally is the tendency to move
towards the center and the left hand is
the tendency to move away from the
center and so for example Christ says
when he's judging the world he says to
the Sheep he says come into my kingdom
and to the goats he says depart from me
I never knew you okay so moving towards
the center moving away from the center
there's a rabbinical teaching that says
exactly that which says you know bring
things closer to you with your right
hand move them away from you with your
left hand right so you now you can think
of it as a person traditionally in any
traditional culture almost every single
traditional culture you eat with what
hand you're right you wash with what
hand you're right you watch with your
left hand
oh because you're moving because you
don't want to eat with what you wash
with you go to the bathroom use your
left hand with your right hand so you
bring towards you with your right hand
you move away from you with your left
hand so you understand that that's just
a basic pattern of being like a person
has a tendency towards unity and a
tendency towards outside towards inside
towards outside that's the that's a
pattern that's a basic pattern of
reality then you can you can apply that
society society has a basic identity and
it has ways in which you move towards
that identity and then it has a way in
which you move away from that identity
but you get moving away our closer is
not moral right because some things you
need to move you need to move away from
you and there's some things also that
move away for you from you for a good
reason right in the sense that you could
be extending yourself out into the world
as well right and so and so it's not
it's not the patterns are not moral
there's nothing in the patterns there's
nothing good or bad they can become good
or bad depending on how they're used for
what reason they're used but the pattern
itself is it just then you can look at
the world and you can what I see when I
look at the world is that's what I see I
see how the pattern is manifested in
different instances now this detaching
of moral judgements from how close you
are to the center or how far you are
from the center is that a Buddhist
concept or does that fall in line with
Christianity because I know Christianity
has an has a and a an emphasis an
emphasis on putting moral judgments on
almost every aspect and Buddhism is the
opposite as far as I know I could be
wrong
so does that does like okay so you said
look there's the center there's the
moving away from the center and you can
move toward you can move towards Center
you can move away from the center it's
not in and of itself a I mean it's not
in and of itself moralistic to do one of
No
one of the others both have danger and
they both have opportunity okay the
Buddhists won't necessarily frame it in
the same terms but he they will they'll
say the passions they'll say you have
these passions on the edges say on in
yourself and those passions are pulling
you are fragmenting you they're pulling
you apart and in the Christian the
Christian way of describing the passions
is the same way especially in the
Orthodox tradition do you have these
passions these desires and these desires
pull you away from your heart let's say
and and you need to go back to your
heart you need to to to to to let's say
so that's a return to the center returns
and you return to the center okay
and do they have in Christianity a
pushing away from the center
well it depends like I said for example
I'll give you an example of a pushing
away from the center which is which is
positive Pentecost Pentecost is when the
disciples are in the high place and then
all of a sudden the the fire of the Holy
Spirit comes down upon them and then
they start to speak and then everybody
can hear them speak in their own
language and so as they're speaking then
everybody else is hearing them speak in
the language that they understand so
that's that's a fire right that's fire
that's the left hand that's moving away
from the center and so the message is is
being dispersed out into the into the
periphery because those who are outside
hear the language hear the message in
their own language and so that's a
left-hand movement it's it's it's moving
out and so so so like I said it's not
necessarily good good or bad and then
then there's also there's a bad left
hand right this idea of giving into your
fire giving into your desires giving in
to your passions is this is being pulled
away you know from yourself and and that
would be represented as a kind of left
hand movement you could say but there
are also right hand sins so st. max was
the Confessor for example talks about
left hand and right hand sins and he
says the left hand sins are you know
gluttony prostitution all the sins of
the passions like you let yourself go to
- to those types of desires and the sins
of the right hand are pride self
sufficient right so now you can see
where the moving into the center can
become negative in the sense of of pride
the sense of thinking that you were that
you don't need anything the sense of
thinking that you're self sufficient and
so like I said those patterns are not
they're not they're not negative or
positive then it's just in their balance
well it just it just depends on on in
this situation a situation it just
depends on what is trying to be
accomplished so entering into the center
in the sense of removing yourself from
your passions and going into the center
in order to to look up and see what's
above you okay so simply just a matter
of appropriateness to the situation
right sometimes you need to be far
sometimes you need to be close yes and
it just depends also you could say a
good
not necessary I was wrong when I said
balance because that would imply that
there's a proper place to occupy in
almost every situation whereas it's
actually different sometimes you just
need to be completely right-handed
sometimes you need to be left-handed
sometimes you need to be a mixture of
both good a good way to so in terms of
center and periphery for example the
good way to understand it is like it's
called memory so if you're moving away
from the center if you remember the
center then it doesn't matter how far
you go right so it's like you if you
remember yourself if you remember god if
you no matter how you say it doesn't you
can go very far and you won't fall you
could say you won't be taken in by
whatever is pulling you out you know
okay so now you see the world like this
you see the world you said you started
to see the world primarily through the
center periphery dichotomy and that's
one that's a that's an easy way to
understand it okay I somebody transcends
those those categories but that's a the
best way to explain it I think is using
hierarchy of like a like a mountain or
pyramid or Center and periphery those
are the best way to explain it so now
when you watch something like a movie
how do you see the movie what are you
looking for are you looking for anything
does it just unconsciously hit you you
realize it doesn't I don't
I usually just watch a movie and then
I'll take a little bit of time and then
I can you give me an example of your
thought process from a recent movie so
that it's fresh in your mind
so some movie that you saw recently that
you went in thinking okay I'm just gonna
watch this movie and then what thoughts
occurred to you and then what thoughts
occurred to you afterwards okay so okay
what did I I just went to see Shazam
with my kids I want to see that movie
and so that the movie Shazam is about a
young man a young boy who becomes a
superhero an adult superhero right and
and he and the movie is for example one
of the images that keeps appearing in
the movie is an image of the carnival
and the carnival keeps coming back and
so for example like if an image like
that keeps coming back especially the
carnival now you say okay I need to pay
attention to this because there's
something going on here and and so the
and so carnival for example is is this
edge the carnival is the edge of the
world the best way to understand it it's
everything was upside down right
everything's spinning everything in the
carnival is spinning all the time you
know the ferris wheel all the rides
everything's spinning and and and
everything is is is is a garish you know
all the colors are garish everything is
there to titillate you and that's in
that way so it's all bad food it's all
it's all spinning it's all laughing and
pleasure and in the very basic sense of
having fun you know and clowns and an
impossible impossible precision games
where you try to hit the center but
you're not gonna hit the center no one
is the center right no one
all those precision games where you win
these big things like it's there they're
very difficult so it's like okay so this
is what's going on and so then you think
okay so the story is about in this [ __ ]
I don't want to give on all these
spoilers but the story in in Shazam is
about dealing with the seven deadly sins
and so it's like okay so here's all of
this going on at same time so the seven
deadly sins kind of come out and possess
this one man you know and then they they
start to kind of attack the world and do
all this stuff so okay so the seven
deadly sins at a carnival it all kind of
makes sense it's like it all kind of
fits together it's not trying to say
anything right it's not it's not like
there's a message but the pattern is
right and so when the pattern is right
where the seven deadly sins appear at a
carnival it's like it fits and then you
when you look at when you're watching it
if you you have a kind of satisfaction
which is a satisfaction of the world
being right even if it's talking about
the upside-down world right it's talking
about these monstrous seven deadly
passions that are coming to just suck to
suck up the world but it's having it in
a carnival which is an upside-down world
already and so all of this is going on
and so it's like even though it's
showing you the
extremes it's Fitz because it's
everything's in the right place and so
when when sometimes what can happen is
if you could have it you could have a
place where it just is wrong where it
just doesn't doesn't work where it's and
that and that's because you're
interpreting it incorrectly or you feel
like it's being forced on the part of
the forest exactly it's just being
forced so there's a desire to to give a
message and so they'll push something in
which will which will force it but the
best way to force it is to because it's
difficult to get away from these
patterns because they're the patterns of
reality thank you all you can do is you
can you can make them upside down you
can twist them right so you can't
totally get rid of them and so I think
that a lot of the the modern kind of
propaganda that's what they do is they
they twist them in a way they kind of
just toss them to make them in like the
idea of yes we need we can't avoid the
masculine feminine archetypes so what
we'll do is we'll put a woman in the
place of the masculine figure and we'll
put a man in the place of the feminine
figure and to mean the man sorry and get
made the man that denigrate them so it's
like so we're still using the same
pattern but we're just doing in a way
that's kind of flipping it upside down
or playing with it in a way that is is
confusing or is meant to create
disjunction you could say how does one
know when they're reading reading too
much into a piece of art something that
Peterson's been criticized with for on a
minor basis like when you when he's
looking at Pinocchio how do you know
you're not reading too much into it so
how does one prevent themselves from
reading too much in is there such a
thing as reading too much into art of
course yeah for sure and I think that
the way that for example what I do is I
just point at the pattern so it's not
I'm not I'm not actually interpreting
the movie usually when I interpret a
movie I'm not interpreting in the sense
of saying this aspect of the movie
represents you know I don't know
represents a Hitler and this aspect this
this this character the movie represents
Stalin and here this is what it's like I
never I would never
make an interpretation of a movie like
that you know I'll say look at the
pattern right here that here are the
here are the the terms of the pattern
right you have someone on the inside
you have someone on the outside how are
they interacting
so we're talking about how does one know
when they're reading too much into art
and you were saying well I'm not gonna
substitute different elements of the
film and say this represents the
struggle of man and this represents the
church this represents Hitler yeah
usually a movie will give you its
pattern it'll it'll it'll lay it a
little because it has to write it the
movie has a pattern in order for you to
even recognize it as a story especially
movies that especially move that are
trying to make money who is that
movies like little art type movies where
the person doesn't care whether or not
anybody watches it usually those you're
hopeless like you're hopeless in terms
of pattern but movies that are actually
trying to attract a lot of people they
have to they have no matter that even if
the person isn't conscious about it in
order to attract a mass amount of
attention they have to embody certain
satisfying patterns that human beings
have within them it's necessary because
the rough people won't go see them or
the cynic would say it's just marketed
well that's not true because we know
movies that have been massively marketed
which have failed right and so you know
maybe they'll have that first bump but
then it'll all go away whereas whereas
if you really want to attract a lot of
attention you need to to have that
pattern and so the idea is the movie
will usually tell you like what's going
on so you just need to let the movie
tell you what's what's happening and
trying to I always try not to go outside
of the movie like at least the least
that I can like try not to reference
anything outside the actual story that's
going on and to just say well this
character says this this is what he does
this is this is how this is his struggle
he's telling you what's the struggling
he's gonna tell you this is this is this
is his problem he's gonna tell you what
the solution is then all I'm gonna try
to do is show you how that is a pattern
and how it would how it's a pattern and
then once I've done that then I can say
okay now this pattern see this pattern
this is the same as this other pattern
this other pattern this other pattern
like see how you know like for example
the pattern of resurrection you know and
that pattern is there everywhere someone
dies or almost dies and then gets back
up at the end it's like you see it in so
many movies you know that's up it's just
it's just there the story you know I can
show you that it's there and then once
I've shown you that it's there then
maybe we can start to talk about what it
means but it's no longer now about just
that one movie right it's about that
pattern which is there and several other
stories and now we can talk about what
it what it's what it's referring to in
terms of existential reality and so to
me what if you stay within those those
frames you have less of a danger of kind
of going overboard one of the things
that happens and it's happened to me is
that sometimes you'll see a pattern and
you won't see a counter pattern you
won't see you'll see you'll you'll want
to see one aspect of the pattern too
much then you won't see something else
that's going on so that's that's wholly
possible can you explain what you mean
you mean to say that you as the person
who's interpreting the piece of art
wants to see a certain pattern and so it
blinds you to a counter pattern yeah for
sure because in other words you're
selectively choosing well that's what a
pattern is right a pattern is is is is
the selectivity because just like a
movie just like any other reality has an
indefinite amount of details right it's
a you could talk about the way the
leaves are moving in the story which
you're not gonna talk about that because
that's not what interests you and so
you'll focus on the characters for
example you could say you know you can
interpret you could you could you could
ask if you were just a kind of nihilist
you could ask why are you focusing on
the characters when you're watching a
movie
why aren't you focusing on on the top
right pixel exactly or though yeah the
way the wind is blowing well some people
who have autism do that they don't
actually look at characters on yeah they
don't look at characters in the eye you
can watch them you can track their their
eye fixations and they don't look so
right now I'm looking at you and I and
they don't watch the characters they
look at the light bulbs they watch how
this swing is swinging yeah in capacity
to kind of bring things together and so
that so it's inevitable that you will do
like you will selectively choose but
sometimes there there can be other
patterns that are there that you that
you might ignore that you might you
might Marge
lies you could say and that's in a way
it's kind of inevitable but hopefully
you try to not to not do it too much and
also to be able to see both and to see
both sides I think the best
interpretation that I've done for movies
have been the ones where I'm able to
show the two sides let's say so almost
sometimes imagine as if you could see
the movie from from different aspects so
let's say you're an artist
and you want to create something that's
not propagandistic that doesn't try to
you don't try to instill your own values
into the art because otherwise you will
call that young Carl Jung would call
that propagandistic versus exploration
art or he called it the difference
between introverted art and extroverted
art so introverted art is the art where
you're trying to you have your own
intentions and it's you're just using
the art as a tool to let the world know
what you think politically is it's
usually political but it could be
whatever could be your the main
character in the film because you're
filming it yourself and you want people
to feel sorry for you it could be
whatever or you want you had a bad
experience with the father and now you
want to make sure that people when they
look at their fathers they have a bad
experience what their father like they
look at fathers negative yeah okay and
then he said there's extroverted art
where just comes through you you're a
conduit for which these ideas flow from
and you don't even know what you're
doing when you do it and until it comes
together as a cohesive home maybe you
can look back but maybe you can't even
look back and as much as you try to
explain it you realize it's deeper than
my explanation you come back one year
from now and there's more there's more
to it more to more to it religious by
religion is like that Bibles are the
Bible's like them so you would call the
extroverted are what advice would you
have for artists who would like to not
fall prey to introverted art they want
to be they want to do art that will last
that will stand the test of time and not
okay right but I think it's difficult
it's difficult for me to answer that
question because I'm not making the kind
of extroverted art that that young is
talking about that I say the liturgical
art that I make is is a is a desire to
participate in a community and a
communal language and so it's very
different it's neither
me trying to impose my vision of the
world on others nor is it this kind of
surrealist type of exploratory art where
you like you said like you just kind of
let yourself go and you don't know what
you're doing it kind of almost Dutch you
know like like a medium or something
it's it's completely different it's
really trying to participate in a common
language and so so like I said I that
that to me I've chosen that as being the
most because the problem with well I
don't see anything wrong with that
because let's say you're a poet you're
using the language of English or
whatever language you're using so you're
using the language of iconography and
then you're constructing within that so
I don't see that as necessarily being
opposed to introverted or extroverted I
mean I don't see that as you trying to
will a certain point of view I just see
it it's you using a language well maybe
it's because maybe it's because of my
idea of the the of how I understand what
you're talking about when you talk about
the extroverted art which is this kind
of you know that's kind of letting it
flow right there almost like a
surrealist like other they make kind of
like ski or how they would they would
automatic writing all that kind of stuff
I think you can just think of it as the
absence of an intentional message right
well yeah no I I think that in terms of
reducing a message I would say I think
that understanding the complexity of
traditional stories it's probably a way
to to help that in the sense that to try
to always see the the Old Testament
characters are some of the best for that
right you can read the Bible the Old
Testament characters and you can read
them as the hero and almost every single
character you can read them as a villain
almost every single one you can see how
they actually there's a shady aspect to
what they're doing okay you can do that
about you can dev up every single
character in the Old Testament it's
really fascinating by the way to do that
and I think that being aware of that is
is probably helpful is to understand
that there are two sides to to the
symbolism all the time there's always
always always and that's something
that's wrong or missing in modern movies
like like you said the one with the the
the reversal of Little Mermaid what was
it called
diera guilt or murder del Toro whatever
yes the shape of water that the white
male was just he's bad there's no good
to him he's just bad if you label them
as bad you're correct
yeah it was knit that was definitely
propagandistic movie that movie in every
in so anyway there was propaganda stick
and so I think that that's it's like I
also I also don't have a problem with
having a bad character like this nothing
there's nothing wrong with that but you
know if you look at like in Lord of the
Rings if you look at a character like
Gollum for example I mean that's a it's
a great character too because he's he's
bad he's a bad character but he's also
like an extension of Frodo you know you
you know that he's where Frodo could go
like if he let himself go he could go
there so you can see Gollum and Frodo
and you can see Frodo and Gollum a
little bit too and so that's a powerful
story because you can you you have these
two characters one which is like a good
character one which is a bad character
but it's also not just it's not a simple
simple relationship there's a
relationship where one is like the
promise of the other in a certain manner
and so that makes it far more subtle and
far more engaging in my opinion I was
trying to think of when is it okay to
actually just have a character which you
can outright categorize as bad and I
wonder if it's only when they are a
representation of Satan so like let's
say Sauron yeah yeah he's like he's not
even embodied right he's like he's just
like he's just an idea almost you know I
mean he he's a being but he's not he's
not embodied in the world they don't
encounter so wrong you know he'd think
that he they encounter him through kind
of 3rd 2nd 2nd tiers or whatever sorry
yeah I think so maybe that's a good way
to understand it I've actually thought
about Sauron quite a bit sometimes about
if if it's too easy
or if that character is too easy
um Bible someone criticized the Bible
say Jesus is too easy
he's too good and the satan is too bad
he's that's too easy
yeah but it's like that's the point it's
supposed to be the extreme so maybe it's
okay when it's supposed to be the
extreme that people don't understant
that category people people don't know
the story of Christ were they you read
the story of Christ
the story of Christ is the most the most
elated and disturbing story at the same
time
Christ has some stuff that people don't
like to cite because it's just if you
want to just make Christ into a simple
good guy story it's not that's not gonna
give us an example Christ says I came to
bring fire to the world to turn brother
against brother Christ said on the cross
father why did how why did you abandon
me Christ said you know Christ said to
Peter bring a sword and then when Peter
takes his sword out it cuts off the ear
of a soldier he stops and says no don't
do that so why did he'd say okay that's
another what I'm saying is that Christ
is a far more complex figure than what
we want to believe that he is you know
think of Christ think of crazy story
think of Christ there as the rabbi who
is the one who who brings who's bringing
the word and the truth and all that and
imagine a [ __ ] washing his feet with
perfume like think of Christ as the one
who hung out with with you know with
Samaritans with strangers and and the
marginalized and all that and that's how
the left want to portray him for example
but then he also goes and hangs out with
a tax collector who's basically a who's
basically a stooge for the Romans who's
who's basically a tool of the of the
Empire to control us and so Christ goes
all directions Christ goes in every
direction it's like you you read once if
you understand the types that that are
in that are in stories and you read
Christ's story you know I've read I've
read scholars complained that what
know how to cook how to frame Christ
because he's a Pisa he's a teacher but
he's he's like a rabbi figure he's also
like a prophet figure but then he is
also like the son of a worker he's also
he's also like a woodworker he's also
you know he hangs out with fishermen
then he talks to and it's like all he
kind of fills up all the stories and so
and so that's why that's the story of
Christ is very it's it's very difficult
to well getting back to propagandistic
this is what's interesting because it's
not simple it's you can't frame this
person is good or bad now that's
standard industry writing never make
your protagonist purely good never make
your antagonist purely bad can we go a
little bit beyond that as to how can we
stop ourselves from consciously trying
to push a message yeah well I mean I
think that I think that there's simple
ways is ways that have been told to us
forever I mean just Aristotle told us
maybe give your character is a fatal
flaw like it's not a it's not it's not
it's not a mystery you know give them
some things that could destroy them you
know and either it does or it doesn't
but make sure that it's there that
you're even your hero has a has a had
something that could devour them and I
would say the same for your enemy right
make your enemy he's convincing make
them make them a twisted version of
something true right don't just make
them a random bad guy who if you make
them a twisted understanding of
something of something which actually
has value then then those that makes for
powerful bad guys like for example the
in the last Avengers movies the Thanos
character that was a great character
it's a great evil character because he
actually he actually talks about things
that people care about today he talks
about ecological disaster he talks about
you know all the things that even the
left cares about but then he pushes it
to such an extreme that you kind of shy
away from it because like okay you okay
where you going with this you know
versus the shape of water which is like
ship water is just trash it's a trash
movie because it's because it
doesn't I mean it's in every single way
like there's so many ways in which
disabled waters trash because it it's
it's almost like a cliche it's like it's
almost a cliche of oh you could guess
each character what's gonna happen to
them you know when it when it starts and
you know that there's either some
there's some especially the bad guy you
know that that the bad guy in the movie
some of the things he says that are so
bad in terms of they're so obvious then
it hurts what is it there's one scene
when he says something he goes to the
bathroom and he said you can learn a lot
about a man whether he washes before I
work and you know you don't do it twice
because that shows weakness yeah it's
like you're so obvious you know you're
so obvious about him being you know
excessive purity and all that stuff but
yeah this part for the course by now
it's not stopped you know there's this
movie coming out just now I said what
does it call it's like these monstrous
dolls and you know it's just not I mean
we've kind of swallowed this this thing
right now and this is this is this is
where society's going in this direction
I don't know where it's going to lead
because it can't sustain itself you
can't you can't have a world of
exceptions do you see Hollywood
contributing to this problem
oh sure since the beginning I think I
think that I think that this problem of
polarization or this problem of what the
thing is that it it falls into the it's
a problem of entertainment culture
itself that's a problem we the idea that
our cultural reference our cultural
artifacts are entertainment that's a
problem we don't we don't we don't
realize that it's it's it's basic it
comes back to what I talked to at first
when I talked about art when I told you
that that traditional art integrates in
us in the culture right so traditional
storytelling was part of festivals was
part of of you know gathering around the
campfire and telling the story of our
ancestors it was about you know
on masks and and and wearing the
costumes and playing out the these
characters but in a manner in which
we're participating in it or so we're
doing it on this date because it's it's
rereads to remember something that
happened you know there's a shared
there's a shared principle united under
purpose yeah purpose and and and just
the fact that we're together all of this
comes together and so the problem is
that now almost all our cultural
artifacts are there to entertain us
they're there to there like a giant
circus they are called the last from
their last remaining cultural artifact
we have is basically a circus it's their
- it's just their Ford for - to keep us
distracted okay last question when do
you see the left going too far I think I
think the left the purpose of the left
is to ask questions you could say is to
say what about this right so you have
some identity it doesn't matter what it
is and then the right hands like this
and then the left hand side yeah well
what about this like the role of the
skeptic yeah like well how does this fit
you know and and why doesn't this fit
and well what did you think about this
you know it's like okay you say you say
this but you're leaving this aside right
here you're not considering this
and so in society that ends up being
exactly kind of what we see which is
this psyche oh you forgot the exception
don't forget the exception there's your
rule but there's also exceptions some
people don't fit so you have to you have
to remember them don't forget the
exception you know the problem happens
when we try to make the exception the
norm it doesn't work you can't have a
world of exceptions just doesn't exist
it can't exist it just crumbled and so I
think that that's the problem that we
have now is that we want we went from
wanting to care for marginalized
identities to this the idea that somehow
an accumulation of marginalization will
make you into a heroic figure it doesn't
doesn't doesn't do that does it just
because you are marginalized doesn't
make you
you're like it's like that's like you're
flipping it upside down it's like the
identitarian czar saying just because I
am of this group I'm fine just because I
am you know white or I'm a man or I'm
this just because of that then I'm
sufficient and I'm fine it's like I'm
pure right that's the that's the bad but
but now what we have this weird crazy
left is the very same thing just upside
down there's a it's like it's like a
competition of purity but like a
competition of exception you can be the
most exceptional in the sense that you
are the most marginalized then then you
you're playing the same purity game just
upside down it doesn't work you need you
need the to like you need you need you
need the the statement of of identity
and then you need things that are there
on the on the margin which say hey hey
don't don't think you've got everything
cuz I'm here to show you that you
haven't accounted for everything right
you haven't accounted for everything
and and I think that that's that's the
normal balance you know alright man
thank you so much well I hope I hope
it's useful see what it looks like